Oh
I'm Chuck Tavita and I thank the people
of CES for inviting me to come have a
discussion with you today I'm not here
to give a presentation I'm here to have
a discussion with you that means that
you have to interact I know as GSB
people you won't have any problem doing
that but it helps me as a speaker
because I get feedback through your
questions and your issues as to whether
or not I'm driving the discussion in the
right fashion does anybody here have as
a primary interest getting consumer
customers okay we're not going to just
talk about that this is about talking
selling and marketing to the enterprise
okay I can't spell retail alright I have
no experience in that space does anybody
care care a lot about going to this
small and medium business SMB market
good because I don't know anything about
that either okay I started my life as an
engineer and then moved into product
marketing and then into sales and then
sales management and then general
management along the way I built two
startup companies one and combined
hardware software and the other a
software company that were somewhat
successful and then my last real job
which ended in 1995 was at a public
company that had been unprofitable for
several years and the vision was that I
would fix sales and everything would be
wonderful
and indeed sales needed fixing but so
didn't the rest of the company suffice
to say that through proper focus getting
back to what we were good at and
discarding doing things we weren't very
good at we did return the company to
profitability in quadruples of stock
price in the course of two and a half
years at that point I had been speaking
at some conferences and getting a lot of
applause and so I decided to see if I
could turn applause into money and hung
my shingle out initially as a company
called sales process systems which was
about helping companies that were at
public stage and later improved sales
productivity revenue growth and revenue
predictability through a set of sales
management and marketing management
methods we actually developed a model we
call the integrated sales management
process model at that point in time it
was viewed as an oxymoron so then
some venture capitalist asked me to work
with some early-stage companies to help
them get funded and build their business
plans and that kind of thing and then
along came a partner and we brought in a
consultant to figure out what to do with
their company we changed the name to
growth process systems and we have a
range of services from the first stuff
that I did to working with companies to
help them get funded to an outsource
capability for getting reference
customers the processes for getting
reference customers initial customers
and selling to the enterprise are very
very different from what you want to do
once you have a proven solution and
you're established in the marketplace
and I'll tell you about that as we go
along so the goal I have is to help you
have a better understanding of the
challenges and best practices for
acquiring your initial enterprise
customers and for the argument's sake
let's say we're talking about companies
that are a hundred million dollars or
greater in size all right this is about
our company you have the notes I don't
need to spend a lot of time on that
we're a small consulting firm I also
teach in continuing studies I'm
currently teaching the last of six
sessions on a course on selling and
marketing software as a service to the
enterprise and I will a summer teach a
six-week course on developing value
propositions and pricing models these
are courses taught in the evening to
people like yourselves who are running
companies and I'll do the SAS class
again in the fall so the the items I'd
like to try to cover today and I assume
we have about an hour and ten minutes
something like that Claire is what I
call moving from vision to execution
we'll talk about does anybody not know
who Jeffrey Moore is or crossing the
chasm everybody has that book right if
you don't buy it tonight there'll be a
test in the morning it is one of the
Bible's of Silicon Valley okay
we have to understand what stage are you
at and I have some methods to help you
do that we'll discuss selling models
various kinds of products and solutions
and then what do you want from customers
a model that we call the value pyramid
which is quite useful for figuring out
how to bundle what it is you are doing
for your
summers and then we'll discuss how you
enter the market what about ideal
customers why do you need to have an
ideal customer list and we'll talk about
value propositions and if we get through
it all then positioning and messaging
architecture so that's kind of what I'd
like to cover so let me ask you what's
your number one goal this year somebody
tell me what your goal is for your
company
Vijay what's your number one goal all
right starting up ok can you so in your
process of starting up relative to
getting customers what's your number one
goal is it getting revenue wrong goal
all right next Robert what's your number
one goal first paying customer ok good
anyone else so I would pause it that the
number you can only have one number one
goal first okay and that it has to be
achieving reference ability when you're
selling to the enterprise market we see
many companies that make the mistake of
I need revenue and I need it fast so
I'll take any customer who can fog a
mirror and has some money in their
pocket ok
and what that is is a sales anywhere
strategy which usually results in
failure failure meaning we plateau out
at some point in our growth that's
unsatisfactory our support costs are
high lots of bad things happen so when
we have that condition its B usually
because we didn't make the appropriate
focus decisions on what not to do and
the decisions what not to do or some of
the most important things as you're
building a company particularly as with
respect to customer acquisition I'm
often called in by boards or CEOs to do
surgery on companies because G's sales
are stalled out it must be those
salespeople figure out what's wrong with
them ok because that's part of what we
do and in fact when we take a look
oftentimes it's that the company never
turned down a customer and so they have
all kinds of verticals that they're in
all kinds of applications are supporting
the support cost as a percentage of
revenue are very high and a lot of bad
things happen ok so
Oh revenue growth should not be your
first goal I'm suggesting it should be
reference ability this does not mean you
don't get money from the customers you
acquire early on as references and I
call it serious money but you're not on
a revenue growth planet if you're the
CEO of a company and you're out looking
for investment and you don't yet have
your references in line you haven't
learned what to do yet because you don't
know what the market wants you haven't
yet turned your silly putty technology
into real products and solutions that
the market wants so I encourage you if
you're a CEO of an early-stage company
out looking for investment be careful of
telling investors what your revenue
growth curve is going to like before you
go through that phase and we'll talk
more about that ok and then the question
is how many of you have both goals
oftentimes CEOs will say well we need
references but boy we need our revenue
growth right now right and that's the
confusion and lack of clarity and it's
one of the most difficult early
decisions you'll have so what you want
to do is you want to find an
intersection between a market
opportunity some product or technology
capability and access to decision makers
who have acute pain about the problem
that you pose to solve we call that the
sweet spot so many times we see
companies focused over here in Silicon
Valley and maybe they don't find a sweet
spot because their baby's so beautiful
all I have to do is show it to the world
and everybody will want to buy it
anybody have that as your business plan
for going forward ok
small companies do not have the
resources to educate a market so I'm
going to tell you several times today do
not have a strategy of educating the
market about how wonderful your product
is ok so you've all been through a stage
where you've had an idea you then sort
of move that into a strategy of how to
go forward with that idea you then
explore and focus some ways of attacking
it in terms of target markets product
types company types and then you go into
execution mode along the way some
business planning and team-building
events occur and the good thing is with
today's tech
Knology we don't just introduce a
product and then have to wait a long
period of time for feedback typically we
get feedback fairly quickly and we
iterate the design as we go forward and
hopefully revenue and cash flow looks
something like that okay so don't design
a perfect product
early on think prototype think a minimal
feature set to get feedback from the
market and many times I see founders who
want to build the perfect product before
they ever go to market this is
particularly true for companies that are
founded out of Israel with engineering
teams from Israel because Israeli
engineers don't care what the customer
wants they know what the customer needs
and I've seen that in several cases all
right and sometimes their success and
sometimes not so your product will
evolve over time that will result in
different value propositions and pricing
models as you go along so I encourage
you to think if you've thought of a very
sophisticated capability early on dumb
it down make it easy for people to
understand how many of you are in
technology of some sort or another a
fair number of you what we tend to do in
technology is we tend to tell complex
stories with Word documents that are
thick and people don't understand
investors don't understand so one of
your biggest challenges is achieving
clarity and simplicity and if you can do
that graphically rather than in words
you'll be better off and I'll show you
some examples as we go forward so this
is Geoffrey Moore okay I assume you're
all familiar with that and over here you
have the risk takers the experimenters
the people that I call we do death by
demo with right we keep showing the
product and we do demos we educate we do
more demos we educate and the issue is
they don't have all the money the people
with all the money are here in the early
majority and the late majority the
people with the big budgets these people
as you probably know don't buy on your
feature set they buy on a banker's
mindset of what's the return on
investment and can they accept the risk
of dealing with
you as an early-stage company the reason
large corporations won't do business
with you is much more about your their
perception of your risk of survival as
opposed to your technology so one of the
things we need to do is try to reduce
that perceived risk in the customers
mind okay so who sells what in this
model well early on it should be the
founding team and you're trying to get
one enterprise customer and you're
really discovering sort of some basic
needs you're going in and you're saying
how do you do it now and what are the
issues around how you do it now what are
the problems and what if we could do x
and y and z would that matter to you do
you have enough pain about this problem
that you'll work with an early-stage
company and will you give me access to
your staff because that's a lot of what
you want and oh by the way I want you to
give me a bunch of money and there's no
product we are not selling a product at
this stage we are selling a vision at
this stage okay and one of the things I
see is people think they have to finish
the product before they can deal with
customers Robert absolutely yes and
they're going to participate with you
with the development and they get some
privileges out of that so they get early
access they get to influence the feature
set you might give them some kind of
access for some period of time before
you go get other customers in their
space be careful of long term exclusives
those can be really dangerous exclusive
only hurts you when you're successful
when you're not they don't matter so be
very very careful about having
exclusives Robert well first off selling
is not about pitching selling is about
listening at this stage okay
selling to enterprises is much more
about consultative approaches that it is
about pitching a product so don't pitch
alright you need to find out do they
have acute pain about the problem that
you're solving if the answer is yes
would they like to learn more about what
stage you're at and your
and now you have a second a meeting with
them and you tell them where you're at
and you explain that you need some help
in taking this to market and they're a
not they have an opportunity to be one
of the early customers to help you and
what you want is staff time and you want
them to become a reference and you want
money all right and by the way on
becoming a reference I'll talk later
about reference types but with an early
stage deal you don't want to write into
the contract permission I get permission
to go talk to their PR department PR
departments are in the business of
protecting you from saying what you want
to say about your relationship with
large enterprise and so what you want to
do is write into the contract the
statement that you want to have all
right and so the issue is this is a
filtering model we're filtering for
acute pain because quite a few of the
prospects will not agree to the set of
conditions that I'm laying out so the
next stage is the learning stage and
here we're trying to get typically
around five enterprise customers where
it's an executive team we have a set of
services that we provide as an
outsourced sales organization you're
combining technology and services
typically a little bit customized for
each customer so that after you have
five in a marketplace you've learned
what the market wants all right and
you're learning about the product
development process now then you go to a
professional sales team a standardized
product and solution it's very
transaction oriented and you're looking
at tens and hundreds of customers to be
acquired all right and the question I
raised for you is where are you in this
spectrum and I'll show you some ways of
measuring that and the other thing that
is really interesting is we see a lot of
companies who are over here hire the
professional sales person or team and
marketing person or team from the large
company in the related space here and
they put them down into this situation
six to nine months later they're gone
they quit or get fired they're very
frustrated that they don't have standard
products and solutions because that's
what they're about is doing transactions
and the CEO thinks everything's ready
and we should be on a revenue growth
path when you're not and I hear
from a number of founding CEOs to say Oh
everything's ready we just need orders
and then we go in and we do an
assessment and we find out that
everything isn't really ready I'm not
talking about the product I'm talking
about value propositions I'm talking
about positioning I'm talking about
pricing models right support
capabilities all those kinds of things
because the product development
typically in technology is about 30% of
the challenge of going to market all the
other stuff is 70%
and the costly part okay so avoid hiring
that execution oriented team or
executive when you're down here so down
here you're not generating demand you
are using a filtering model to find out
if they meet your criteria and we'll
show you some more about that
here you are generating demand it's a
very expensive game
all right sales and marketing as a
percentage of revenue here typically is
going to run somewhere between 35 and 60
percent of revenue that's right 35 to 60
percent of revenue big big number it's
one of the reasons you need an
investment okay and you can look at all
the successful companies and they're in
that range when they're down in here
here we don't have that kind of money to
spend so we're very selective think
about it this way think about the next
six to nine months how many enterprise
customers can you bring in to your
company and support properly it's a
limited set two three four or five some
small number why shouldn't you be
selective in terms of who you give the
privilege to of being your customer
interesting concept well how do you do
that you have a list of the
characteristics that you want an ideal
customer criteria list that we'll talk
about more all right and you're very
selective as to who you agree to let be
your customer okay how are we doing so
far
does it make sense all right have you
seen all this stuff before okay all
right so this is okay all right going
ahead so the challenge is filtering not
educating you don't have the resources
in the bandwidth to educate the market
all right you're familiar with the the
sales learning curve by Leslie in
Holloway I assume right that they did in
2006 that's a very good paper on this
particular area so I told you I was
going to
you understand what stage you are at and
this is a set of charts we've developed
so depending upon your funding you might
be in discovery and learning or
execution with regard to marketing are
your value propositions non-existent
value hallucination as Steve Blank says
by the way that's a very good book four
steps to the Epiphany by Steve Blank if
you haven't read that a very good read
Steve is a very successful entrepreneur
I did start at eight companies for
wildly successful and he has lectured
here he also is a professor at Haas and
he and I have done a number of events
together so it's a real good book the
four steps to the Epiphany pipeline is
our pipeline non-existant have we
started to develop it or is it fully
developed and you can see I don't need
to go over each one but it this one on
partners you know channel partners
raises an interesting issue how many of
you think your initial market approach
is going to be through channel partners
good because channel partners do not
establish your references as somebody
that resells your product okay in some
fashion through a variety kinds of
relationships they they're in the
business of taking your product once you
have proven you can get customers make
money with it and now participating with
you in some fashion by providing some of
the set of services of going to the
market but they are not effective
typically at helping you establish your
references product development all right
what's the what stages a yet prototype
prototype alpha beta or production is
there a product roadmap all right is it
preliminary is it more detailed and
functional so you can see as you start
to look at these components you can
measure where you are with regard to
sales who is doing the selling alright
is there a sales process do we have a
sales process model that is proven or
not how many customers do we have do we
have a worldwide perspective and what
we're doing how many of you are going to
go worldwide in the first year of your
operation I would suggest you consider
doing that when I built my companies
I was traveling internationally within
the first year and I think it's pretty
important today especially when the
barriers for purchasing around the world
have gone to zero through the internet
okay and then with regard to services
which are really really important who's
doing them are they productized or not
right and are they provided by
yourselves or by system integrators
that's another issue for you to think
about system integrators early on are
not very effective for providing your
services and the other thing is when
you're getting your first customers why
would you want to give the success of
your customer to somebody else you want
to control that success so while system
integrators may have a role to play in
your future once you're a proven
solution you must have to be careful
about trying to use them early on Robert
oh that's my firm growth process of coop
sorry yeah I'm not trying to give an ad
for that yeah good good pickup okay so
what do you want from your early
customers you want their time you want
them to look at your specs you want them
to look at test your prototypes you want
meetings with them all right you want
their help right that's that's a group
of people so it's really important if
you're going to an enterprise deal such
as the type I'm saying which is a
development partner customer
relationship that the person who makes
the decision to work with you has the
political power to allocate resources
right because if they don't have the
you aren't going to get the time of the
staff all right and as I said you want
to get very clear and what kind of
reference they're going to become now
you do want money and and here my
suggestion is let's assume three years
from now your deal size for argument's
sake is $100,000 or $200,000 you ought
to get at least half now all right not
$10,000
not $5,000 okay and that brings up an
interesting point what's the definition
of a customer my definition includes
must-haves
giving us money so those of you who have
three trials of one sort or another
those aren't customers those are free
trials they may have value for you but
they do not have the level of commitment
that a customer has okay so without the
money you won't get the commitment of
the staff because imagine for a minute
that Jenny comes in to see me and she
pitches a particular solution I'm
interested in and she gets significant
money from me and Thomas comes in and
says I'll let you have this for free at
this stage where do I assign my team
where I allocated the money all right so
the purpose of the money is to get the
access to the resources of the
enterprise customer to help you develop
the product okay what do you want from
later customers well it is about revenue
sorry clearly it is about if you have a
land and expand model growing from
departmental to enterprise wide use all
right you want to upsell and cross-sell
and if you're in a subscription kind of
business it is about getting renewals in
the tent in the software space which I
work a lot in now it's software as a
service is the name of the game and if
you don't have renewal rates that are
well above 90% you will have
unsatisfactory financial results all
right and so what that means for example
in that particular segment is you must
have a very high value placed on
customer delight go ahead Lauren yes
that means you sell other modules or
other components that you could have
sold all right they sell them other
stuff yes DJ I think I have something on
that adds to me that quite asked that
question again if we go through it and
it's not here and that's an interesting
issue but what technology companies in
particular fail to do is understand the
value that they provide for the customer
and so what happens is they tend to
price their offering low and many times
we see the opportunity to raise price
substantially and good things have
tire kickers go away access to higher
level executives increases top level
executives don't solve $10,000 problems
they delegate that three levels down if
you want that's what you want that's
fine and not bad just know that's the
level that you're going to deal at if
you're trying to solve an
enterprise-wide problem and I'll show
you what that means in a minute
then then you perhaps need to be at a
higher level this chart speaks to the
characteristics of enterprise customers
that are early adopters okay and those
who purchase later on so for example
does the early adopter require that the
product or solution be fully defined no
do they require vetted value
propositions no are there decision
makers typically visionary yes do they
typically have good political high
political power in their corporation to
take risk yes all right they're not
looking for references so back to the
ideal customer criteria if you in a
filtering model and you're talking to an
executive and a firm you think you want
to sell too early on and they say well
what do you have as references that's
probably not a good Orly customer you
put them in the bucket for the majority
and you keep them warm through
communications over time until you're
ready to go after them they don't expect
sales tools developed and and so on and
of course the reverse is true over here
okay so this by the way has implications
for who should be doing the selling
these people that sell over here ten
more or less to be talkers and this is
more of a challenge of listing Robert
broker contacts is the best broker
contacts come from advisers from people
like myself from potential investors
from professors who may know
opportunities right now there's a good
and bad side to a brokered contact it
gets you in the door it does not equal a
sale you must still have a structured
sales
to go through two successful clothes and
the other thing is that if all you've
done is sold through brokered contracts
you haven't yet proven you can go when
that when you didn't have one of those
when there's a door that you got to bust
through okay was that answering your
question yeah that's the best approach
and you want to utilize those as much as
you can
early on okay so how many of you plan to
sell in a top down model where you're
going in at a high level one I see one
hand okay the initial target is the
enterprise you develop the enterprise
app it is classically at what's called a
complex sales model and there are a
variety of methodologies for how you do
that kind of selling you know Miller
Heiman a total target account Task Group
solutions selling and the like you need
to qualify early for good fit and stop
selling when there's not good fit one of
the things that sales organizations and
individuals who are selling at this
stage as well do a poor job of is
stopping selling when there's low
probability of success so we you need to
get clear on what early qualification
for goods that means have a list of
qualification criteria and be ruthless
about using that okay it's essential to
get these people to give you time it may
involve trials but they don't have to be
true free necessarily in fact what we
find with the enterprise solution
providers that are my clients is they've
typically moved from free trials to
trials that are charged for typically
somewhere in the ten to $50,000 Connell
level for a solution that might cost two
hundred two thousand dollars a year
alright why it's called buyer commitment
right and what they find is the
conversion rate for the charge trials is
60 70 80 percent 90 percent for the free
trials it's 10 20 30 percent so
substantially different and yet we have
technology companies and early stage
founders and say well gee I'm just
unproven I can't ask for money you know
the only reason
enterprise will spend time in meetings
with you is because they believe that
you and your team are the best team to
solve the problem that you're going to
solve for them as soon as they don't
believe that the meetings will stop
because buyers are always making
decisions to stop purchasing cycles all
right
so equally on your side you should be
evaluating how well they fit and
deciding where to spend your resources
okay you will have higher selling costs
per order with this top-down model but
once you get management commitment
adoption success is given because they
have the political power to commit the
resources all right and so you get
faster adoption if you get that top
level commitment alternatively there's a
bottom-up model typically a land and
expand kind of model where you're going
in at a departmental level all right and
you're getting users excited and initial
revenue in fact maybe advertising or
subscription-based revenue growth will
be slow early sales do not establish
your reference ability and the
probability of getting the enterprise is
low I have a client in Sausalito that
solves the problem of reducing workers
compensation for fortune 100 companies
through a software-as-a-service model
and when I got involved with him a few
years ago their process was to do what I
call plant seeds they had trials
everywhere hoping they would blossom
into real deals right real deals being
along the order of a quarter million
dollars here and they were very
unsatisfied with the success rate of
that of blossoming into real deals and
so we I actually became an interim VP
there for about nine months
sales and marketing to restructure the
whole process and what we did was we
focused on the value that we're
providing for the customer we started
calling higher to get commitment and
then we package to trial into the
contract such that if we meet the
success metrics for the trial rollout
becomes automatic and we negotiate the
contract before the trial and that's not
an easy thing to do all right but none
of this is easy
okay so it's not impossible
now the second target then is you grow
to the enterprise level and the
challenge is how do you grow
departmental use - enterprise wide use
okay so the investment for this model
typically is higher okay now I want to
talk about three product types which go
along with what we've been talking about
there's an enterprise solution that
solves an enterprise problem
it changes the way work is done across
the enterprise alright is very much must
be a top-down model requires a
high-level executive decision
who has the political and resource
allocation power that's one of the
things you need to learn to measure is
do they have resource allocation power
do they have the political power to take
the risk in their organization
committees are very common to give input
right and free trials are typically not
productive in this model and your
typical examples would be companies like
Oracle and sa P now then there's a
departmental solution which solves the
departmental problem changes the
workflow in the department and it is
what's called land and expand we'll get
this department working up and
successful and then we'll expand to
another group in the company and my
client right now technologies in the CRM
space is out of that model and they're
doing about 180 million dollars now and
growing quite nicely and by the way
they're hiring they're looking for
people so so we secure a beachhead
cross-sell and upsell typically does
require a departmental executive
decision who has resource allocation
power within their domain and free
trials may or may not be productive for
generating sales and these are some
examples and then there's a point
product okay this is a point product
it's a Livescribe pen that allows me to
take notes capture audio and have the
notes synced with the audios that I can
share them with people later alright
Gravatt is an interesting point product
if anybody's not familiar with grab grab
at GW ABB IT it scrubs the contact
information out of your emails and puts
it automatically in Outlook right so
it's sold to individuals who happen to
work at enterprises
and they have no political or resource
allocation power so don't fool yourself
if you're in this category that you're
selling an enterprise solution it does
not change the workflow in the
enterprise it is clearly a much more
viral kind of model and free tyre trials
are typically expected to generate sales
and examples would be Salesforce in the
early days grabbed at live squad
subscribed in others so those are kind
of the three categories and I'd like you
to if you're in two categories of the
three that I described you probably have
some focus work to do okay so the same
questions apply independent of what kind
of business you're in when you're
selling to the enterprise what problem
are we solving for customers and when I
teach my class on selling and marketing
SAS to the enterprise or doing value
propositions I ask each person in the
first class to get up and tell me what
problem they solve for the customer 15
words or less 70 to 80 percent describe
the features of their product it's
happens every time I do it okay so this
is not easy to do to put yourself in the
customers shoes to understand what
you're doing for them and if you can
describe it in quantitative terms as it
impacts them financially it's better
alright are your value propositions
clear and quantified how often do you go
to a website for a company to see what
they do and you can't figure it out or
you do figure it out and then you go
visit and the CEO says all the website
isn't right we're doing this right the
websites the most important sales tool a
company has and one of the most
important functions of a website is the
ability for a non prospect to qualify
themselves out without ever talking to
any of your people somebody who is not a
prospect for you who qualifies
themselves out has high value for you
they don't waste your time all right so
think about what you're doing and your
website in those terms
the initial goal as I've said I'm
suggesting very strongly it should be
reference ability then what do you want
from customers at various stages as we
mark
through right discovery learning and
execution and his customer delight
central to what you're doing I had a
great experience today in the consumer
space which I know nothing about with
Zappos I had bought a pair of Allen
Edmonds shoes several hundred dollars
and they're the wrong width so I called
him up and I said I want to return no
problem with send either label by email
and gee we don't have the width you want
would you like us to go to other
websites to see who has it they went out
to other web sites found another and I
and I placed in order for their correct
size do you think I'm gonna go back to
Zappos next time I want shoes you bet
all right excellent customer service
same with Tiffany's Tiffany's and and
these experiences I know our consumer
but Tiffany's several years ago my
daughter my younger daughter is the
senior legal counsel for the Flo TV
division of Qualcomm and she had done
some work for me some legal work on
contracts and didn't want compensation
so I wanted to get her a nice gift and
so I started looking at Tiffany's and I
looked at all the different kinds of
things that she might want and I saw a
few so I called in I said to somebody on
this they had a glass globe and I said
can that be inscribed gee I don't know
it's downstairs to the two floors I'll
go get one and I'll find out and call
you back five minutes later yes it can
be inscribed so when I need that kind of
thing I'm gonna go I know where I'm
gonna go all right because it's hard to
find wonderful customer experience
Amazon same way right what does Amazon
great at selling books no providing
excellent customer experience that's
what they're really good at okay are
your corporate goals clear and published
how many of you have corporate goals on
a page of a PowerPoint well develop it
okay why is it important it's really
important for communicating with your
team as you add team members it's super
important for developing sales
compensation once you have sales people
all right and we often find there's a
disjoint connection or not connection
between corporate goals and sales
compensation system and that results in
very bad things expensive sales for
closed rates and what I call entering
markets through sales accidents which is
dangerous
okay how should the sales process evolve
do you know who to sell to I think in
this deck I'll show you a model of
figuring out who to sell to we have an
approach we call the value pain matrix
where we list the problems we could
solve we list the title types of auto
care and then we evaluate them on a
number of factors like do they have
acute pain can they create budget do
they have political power right
are they the owner of the problem early
on you do not want to sell across
departments that results in long sales
cycles and bad close rates who makes the
decision to buy oftentimes when you
enter into a discussion in an enterprise
you have a sponsor who brings you in and
then somebody else called the economic
buyer makes the decision to buy
companies have a practice of preventing
sales organizations from getting to the
economic buyer right they protect them
the cloak you need to be able to find
out who's doing what role and in this
regard you might look at Miller Heiman
strategic selling I think it's called
the new strategic selling you want to
understand what are the characteristics
of an economic buyer a sponsor a coach a
user buyer and a technical buyer all
right most people that you'll deal with
have the ability to say no in terms of
stopping the process moving forward the
only person who can say yes in and of
their own power is the economic buyer
that is not a title there's no title
that's economic buyer it varies
according to the deal it varies
according to the length of your
relationship with the company if in fact
you're viewed as mission-critical
and this is your first deal with this
company all right
the economic buyer is likely to be quite
high on the other hand if it's your
tenth deal to a division of the company
economic buyers liable to be a
purchasing agent right so learn to
evaluate the people in the buying
process through a methodology and there
are several that are commercially
available how long does it take to
implement in the old software world as
an example you know we bought a million
dollars where the software and four
million dollars were the services and it
didn't work for the first year all right
and so people had a lot of bad stories
about places like sa P and Oracle and
the others today in the software world
through software as-a-service
you
you can give a new customer a successful
first user usage experience within weeks
and whatever it is you're doing whether
it's in software or technology or not
you want your customer to become
successful quite quickly to get
enthusiastic about what you're doing and
then what about channels is it makes
sense to use them initially or not how
much will they pay - the question you
raised and we'll get into that so ok
we're still doing ok yeah all right this
is a model called the value pyramid I've
used this for years in classes and with
clients relative to how are we going to
position what we sell how are we going
to bundle our domain expertise in a way
that creates maximum value for the
customer and maximum price or deal size
for us okay so down at the bottom here
your component your a bolt your a
semiconductor all right your your a
newspaper all right up at the top you
are a much more extensive solution for
an enterprise now the attributes are
different ok down here it's price
delivering quality markets very large
typically horizontal up at the top deal
sizes large differentiation from
competitors is high and market is
smaller ok typically so I'm not here to
tell you where you should be in this
model at all I have no bias in that
regard what I am here to tell you is you
cannot be at the bottom on the top and
if you're not where you want to be you
have to get there quickly because of
organizational and cultural issues well
why is that well down at the bottom
success is the customers responsibility
think cell phone good out-of-the-box
experience not much in the way of
personal support go to the website get
some information download some more
software ok all right
and so you will get people in your staff
who know how to do those things really
well
up at the top success is much more the
suppliers responsibility think a set of
robust services all right that go along
with your product to help that customer
be successful to ensure success Robert I
don't think I'll show you an example in
the next slide and then because we moved
from somewhere in the middle to up with
my second start up okay
in the initial company we built our deal
sizes were millions and they were very
strategic to our customers so the answer
is it is and we'd have to get into the
details all right the Devils in the
details but think about in your what
you're doing for your customers who own
success of your product is that the
customers or is it yours and what do you
need to do relative to organizational
structure culture around customer
delight and resources that you need to
assemble to do that job well okay so I
slide I wanted to get to in my second
startup it was a software tools business
all right and when I joined it was a
professor from the University of
California who would go to a trade show
and sell a few and then we go to another
trade show and sell a few and I was VP
of everything initially and then ended
up being VP worldwide sales and so
initially our our order size was about
15,000 and we sold a couple licenses and
some maintenance and some user training
all right we went through a year of no
new product capability from engineering
which is a death in that business all
right and I'd been around the world
holding seminars on the product offering
that we had at that point so I sat down
with the VP of Marketing that we had and
the VP of Support Services and I said
we're gonna have a new product offering
cuz I've got to do a new set of seminars
and I can't go back with the same thing
and engineering is not going to help
what are we gonna do about that we came
up with what we call a solution model we
called it our pilot project
and it was a set of stuff now we were
not turning the company into a services
company we were using services to
leverage the product sales all right and
what was really interesting for me in
addition to all this stuff was we said
we're gonna help you dramatically
improve the quality of your design
reviews
I had seven vice presidents that son
each jump out of their chairs and say
I'll buy one
I had vice presidents at places like
Xerox and General Dynamics and Hughes
Aircraft yes I'll take it because we are
terrible at design reviews and it's
hurting us financially it's taking us
too long to roll our projects out that
was in a havi right about here we had
this domain expertise that we could
package into a solution for the customer
build the deal size build the value for
the customer differentiate ourselves
from competitors and made it easier to
work with new companies and new markets
because we were partnered for their
success we would come back and do
success reviews right that was part of
the package
yes Robert no no their design review
their design review process they were
not doing design in other words they
would do a design review and then later
they find an error in the design many of
them right so they didn't feel like they
had good process for doing that and and
our capability as packaged here
dramatically improved that I just cite
that as an example each of you have
domain expertise that you're giving away
for free right now
and you need to start thinking about how
you can package it in to your product
you'll productize it eventually but
initially maybe you're not ready to
productize it but it should be packaged
in with what you're doing
companies will do business with you
because of the expertise of your team
right they don't do it because they love
your product early on it's because of
the expertise of your team so package
that expertise in a way that maximizes
the value in their minds you know we're
trying to approach this from a customer
perspective okay so this is how
customers look at this when I was a
sales
for a Fairchild Semiconductor a long
time ago I spent time with component
engineers at places like Hughes and
Xerox and General Dynamics getting my
integrated circuits on the approved
vendors list all right I was operating
down here up at the top you're
contributing to strategic issues
organizational issues and again I'm not
saying where you should be but these are
choices you get to make and some of the
choices are what not to do in terms of
this so when I hear from a founder our
product can be sold to consumers our
product can be sold to enterprises it
doesn't matter it's about the domain
expertise that you are going to build
about your customers problem and you
don't have enough resources early on to
do it for everybody when I hear we're
gonna have a vertical approach and these
are the first four verticals we're gonna
do no you're not not successfully
because when you approach a market
vertically that means that people in
sales marketing supporting development
have domain expertise about the needs of
that vertical there is no way in hell
you can put together domain expertise
about several verticals in an
early-stage company and even larger
companies have difficulty doing that
makes sense okay so let's talk about how
we go to market this is the
entrepreneurs dream I have a product
idea we'll design it I'll set some goals
I'll hire a bunch of salespeople in a
way we go anybody been in a company like
that
yeah sure well here's a better way in in
my view you do the strategic stuff that
we talked about earlier then you select
some candidate target markets you
propose some ideal customer criteria and
as Steve Blank says you propose value
hallucination this is your view of your
value before it's been vetted in the
market okay and as Steve also says very
well there are no facts inside the
building there are only facts outside
the building so get outside the building
all right facts come from customers and
prospects now then you select some
target companies in those target markets
and you select some target titles that
you think should care this is all
kind of done through database research
okay
Hoover's that kind of stuff then we get
out in the field and we talk to him we
find out do do you have a cute pain
about the problem I'm solving well if
you can't describe the problem you're
solving you're gonna have difficulty
with that solution that discussion sorry
so that's why we emphasize don't talk
about your features talk about the
problem you're gonna solve for the
customer do you own the problem alright
can you create budget because the budget
doesn't exist for this solution it
doesn't exist yet and do you have the
power to allocate resources to work with
us and what you want is yeses for all of
those there may be some other attributes
like if it's process-oriented or
whatever okay and you use that as your
filter now we iterate through a number
of target titles through a number of
target companies and a number hopefully
not more than two target markets but you
might find the first target market
doesn't isn't isn't great so you should
have a couple of backups that she could
go to right I was involved with a
company in Seattle in the clean tech
space and the problem they were solving
was reducing the cost of energy for
distributed operations down the power
line it turns out that what you pay for
power is a function of the voltage and
utilities have to guarantee a minimum
voltage at the end of the line so near
customers pay a lot more because they're
you and it's a function the square of
the voltage and so they're their
technology regulates the voltage all
along the way and they were going to go
to utilities as the market and they
asked me to come in and help them and I
ended up doing a interim role with them
as well and the problem with utilities
is what they're not early adopters
typically they're becoming so maybe PG&E
was smart moderate meters is an example
of an early adopter but but typically
utilities are very slow to make
decisions right they're bureaucratic
there are people protecting the way of
doing business
all right and so we changed the second
market we went to was those companies
that have distributed operation
like 7-eleven like McDonald's and so
where we could get a central decision in
enterprise and there were distributed
operations who would benefit from this
voltage regulation cost-saving approach
okay
now as you do that as you're out talking
to these customers you're moving from
assumptions to facts you need to be
objectively critical of yourselves about
what our assumptions I'll go through
conversations with companies and they'll
make some statements about some things
relative to customers and markets don't
say is that an assumption or is that a
fact and they'll say oh that's a fact
and then we go through a next phase of
the conversation later on I say give me
the numbers about those facts oh you
want numbers excuse me facts come in
numbers for me okay and so be
objectively critical of yourselves about
what are facts and what are assumptions
and then you need to notice this this is
a difficult part choose a market what do
you mean I can only sell in one market
initially yes if you're familiar with
Jeffrey Moore is crossing the chasm it's
the beachhead concept okay
now then you acquire your development
partner customers who are giving you
money but also access to their staff
you're refining your product you're
developing your sales tools you're
refining your value propositions and
developing your sales process I was
involved with a company in 1999 actually
that was a hosted play then we didn't
know was called software-as-a-service
and the problem we were solving was
improving the supply chain which was
external to an enterprise for the
problem of packaging electronic devices
like laptops it turns out that the
process of designing and manufacturing a
package is quite complex often involving
a hundred parts and what happens is
product development is late we've
announced we're going to introduce it at
a show right and so packaging gets
squeezed in terms of the time it can do
its job and therefore the quality of the
packaging declines that results in an
increased rate of damage to the product
and returns financial value okay so we
developed a solution for improving the
and by the way most of that package work
is done by vendors who are external to
the enterprise
so we developed a solution for fixing
that problem better faster cheaper with
the supply chain so the first customer I
got was Hewlett Packard in Boise two
hundred thousand dollars a year on a
renewable days basis and I went back to
them three months after they had product
and we're using I said how are you doing
on integrating the supply chain with our
solution oh well we're not going out to
the supply chain yet we love the product
we're using it for internal control this
year we're gonna do the supply chain
next year what do you think I said when
I went to IBM you cannot learn these
kinds of subtleties with a bunch of
smart people like yourselves sitting
around a table doesn't happen all right
you only get that kind of thing relative
to value with talking with customers so
one of the important things about
developing value propositions is once
you've sold something go back and ask
right and that's something companies
don't do a very good job now then we're
moving from at this point from learning
to execution phase now we hire that
expensive execution team and sales
marketing and support and we go into a
repeatable model a process-oriented
model where we can say if we add a
resource in sales marketing or support
our revenue will go up by X amount and Y
period of time and once we know that we
now have a money machine right and now
we need growth growth investment to grow
it and the investors will happily dump
buckets of cash on you if you can prove
that all right now this is a much lower
risk model for entering a market than
the previous one okay failing fast is
what's important when you're down here
learning capturing that learning in a
structured fashion such that you grow
and learn new things as you move ahead
is what's really important okay so what
about premium I had the CEO of inside
view in to speak to my class in
continuing studies the other night and
he uses a freemium model and so freemium
says you offer a free version it has
limited capabilities and then customers
will upgrade to the better better
product and they'll buy it okay and
some of you plan on doing that kind of
thing no yes maybe okay so that here's
the important thing about it it's good
for large horizontal markets it's much
more about point products and maybe
departmental than it is about enterprise
and it requires a well baked offering so
you don't want to do this early on
because you don't want those first users
to say this stuff sucks I'm not going
back there right in Umberto's case the
CEO of InsideView he said it was two or
three years after they launched before
they went to a freemium model okay has
to be well baked and it is not a free
trial and it is capital intensive
he's already raised 19 million dollars
he didn't say if he was profitable my
strong guess is the answer's no and that
he's going to be doing another round so
it's a capital intensive game so one of
the things of course you all look at I'm
sure is how much capital do you need to
get to sustainability right and
typically with subscription model kinds
of products what we find in the software
space is the investment required is 1.3
to 1.7 times what it was for the
on-premise game because the cash comes
later all right so software as a service
is not cheaper it's not doesn't require
lower investment and if you have not a
software product but a subscription
model where people are paying you
overtime you need to take that cash flow
into account and client in the
investment that you need now this is
just some data collected by a group I
work with called soft letter if you're
in the software space soft letter comm
is a very good newsletter they hold
events four times a year called SAS
University I'm a speaker at those and
the next ones in Washington DC July 20th
and they hold them different places
around the country but you can get their
newsletters for not a lot of money and
what he's saying here is the the results
are that freemium is not that successful
for companies trying to sell to the
enterprise I won't go over all the
details you can look at the notes later
ok just one example there may be others
question No
you guys aren't asking me many questions
you're not disagreeing with me either
there's something wrong with this group
Stanford Business School group you got
to be disagreeing with me come on okay
so let's talk about ideal customers
right how do we describe an ideal
customer well they have the problem you
solve they know they have the problem
you solve if you have to convince them
that they have the problem you solve
what do you have a long cell cycle right
so they have to know they have that
problem and they have to have acute pain
now how do I measure acute pain I ask
the decision-maker is it number 1 2 or 3
in your budget for this year solving
that problem if it's not it's not a cute
in my view you may have a different
method but define a method for measuring
acute pain define a way of asking about
it such as you can determine if they
have that or not will they provide early
access to the economic buyer or not as I
said companies are in the business of
preventing you from accessing the
economic buyer now imagine it's 1998 and
you have the best sales force automation
solution in the world at that time was
called SFA and you're working with the
team the committee and your people are
coming in and you're doing the
evaluation and it's six nine months in
the cell cycle now you meet with the
economic buyer and the economic buyer
says my team loves what you have and
you're getting pretty excited we're
gonna get an order but I have a problem
all of my budget is allocated to y2k
this year next would you like to have
known that in the first or second call
yes all right I see you grinning Robert
that kind of thing happens trust me all
right and of course when it happens if
there's a salesperson involved and they
do it many times they are going to be
there much longer okay if it says you as
the founding team that's your time
that's your critical resource is there
consensus on value versus price how
often you go into a deal and they're
trying to beat you up on price right if
you've done a good job of understanding
the value and priced it appropriately to
map into their payback requirements and
they're beating you up on price go down
the street to the person who doesn't do
that
alright remember you're only trying to
get five customers initially or maybe
it's three or seven but it's a small
number all right so be very selective
then of course there's always a thing of
how big are they
what vertical are they in where are they
we don't want to spend any money on
traveling I don't think that's the right
approach but we hear that and are they
willing and able to pay all right now
these are the attributes that we don't
focus up on enough that are really
critical all right do they have the
problem do they have a cute paint about
what we proposed to do can we test for
that adequately or not okay
so have a list on PowerPoint no I use is
it number one two or three in your
annual budget for this year solving that
problem that's my approach you may have
another approach all right in other
words I'm asking the decision maker the
economic buyer for this kind of a
solution very early
what are your critical issues your
critical success factors you're trying
to do with this year I don't know the
answer to that but be careful of having
nice to have provide products and
solutions that are must-haves
nice-to-haves
don't win if that's all they do all
right you have to have a must have all
right so that's one of the reasons why
you want to work with your development
partner customers to develop a product
offering that is a must-have for their
market nice-to-haves
get lots of meetings and lots of demos
and very few orders soft value we call
it soft value soft value alone does not
float the boat okay so I said I made
this point earlier how many customers
can you take on in the next period of
time it's a limited set so ration out
those valuable slots to customers who
meet your criteria by the way I said
early on I was going to talk about about
the importance of simplicity and clarity
your idea
customer criteria one page of PowerPoint
no more than ten bullets one line four
bullet large font all right getting
clear is really really hard you must get
the complexity out of your thinking and
sometimes it takes outsiders such as
your investors and your advisors your
consultants whatever to help you do that
why because you're hugging your trees
you're dealing with your daily issues as
you should be you have difficulty seeing
your forest so an example I was working
with a company that came out of network
support companies and it's the early
stage and they were gonna there their
problem they were gonna solve was
reducing the cost of support for network
equipment companies okay and so we were
going through sort of an assessment
phase and I said well does your software
product know all the devices that are on
the network yeah we know that are they
all on maintenance no typically not does
it know which ones are on maintenance
and which ones are not
yes it knows that automatically well
couldn't you propose a value proposition
that is about improving revenue for your
customers by allowing them to go to
their customers if those that customer
would put all the devices on giving them
a deal on a per device basis but raising
the maintenance contract never thought
about it and where they were hugging
their trees and I was looking at their
forest okay doesn't mean I'm smarter I
just have a different perspective that's
all all right so you need somebody with
an outsider's perspective and the other
thing relative to simplicity and clarity
you need to develop a story about what
you do that's so simple your mother can
understand it okay that's really
important okay assuming your mother's
not an engineer okay so let's talk about
value propositions because this is
really really key my view is it is a
concise statement
ideally quantified about what you do for
your customer about improving revenue
reducing cost or improving control doing
value proposition work is really really
hard I have a client in San Francisco
right now where the CEO said I want you
to train my product line managers to
improve our value propositions because I
looked at the value propositions and
they're very complex and they don't have
any quantification it would have been
much easier job if I just gone in and
done the work for them training the
people to get out of there very tactical
mindset and raise the level of their
thinking to a financial problem is a
difficult thing to do okay what a value
propositions do they answer these kind
of questions
is that less risk is it faster is it
cheaper is it better all right nothing
about features on this list all right
will it enhance my career there's a
concept in Miller Heiman strategic
selling called wins versus results all
right results are the results for the
company the measurable impact the win is
the win for me the decision-maker
deciding to work with you all right
you always want to understand the career
impact of the decision-maker in working
with you and your team and you want to
minimize that risk or find people who
will take the level of risk that you
provide okay so how do we develop value
propositions you've heard me say it
before simplicity is really key describe
the problem solved from the customers
perspective one page a PowerPoint large
font develop before-and-after views day
in the life of what happened before your
solution arrived and then after your
solution arrived and graphical is better
than text and I've found that it's
extremely hard for insiders to do
graphical views of the problem they
solved for their customers okay
you map value to pain you craft messages
by title or function as derived from
your value proposition how many of you
have companies that already have tag
lines okay do you have clear value
propositions maybe not okay
yeah and that why because tag lines are
cool they're fun right moving at the
speed of business whatever your tagline
is okay but that's not where this the
hard work occurs it has to occur at the
value proposition level okay next page
same thing we're still developing we
then make assumptions on parameter
ranges what our parameters revenue cost
control kinds of metrics
now this is why I advise people don't
solve problems or try to solve problems
you don't know anything about why
because if your assumptions about these
things are way off the mark you won't
get the second meeting now what happened
in the bubble xx something you may be in
this category I don't know so the
20-somethings from Kansas came over here
and they said that's an interesting
market I don't know thinking about it
I'm going to own it next week and the
VCS funded that right and now most of
them have gone back to Kansas because
those companies generally didn't survive
okay you develop preliminary
quantification from a TCO perspective
they may not know what TCO is total cost
of ownership the customer has other
costs besides what they pay you they
have to do some training they may have
to put in some infrastructure let me
have to make some changes so you have to
understand the customers costs right and
it's better if you get them to tell you
what their costs are rather than you
enter you assuming but initially because
you know something about the problem
you're solving you should have some
estimate and typically their cost of
switching to your solution are non zero
right they may be substantial you then
test your preliminary value propositions
and then how do you know you have a good
value proposition do you come to talk to
somebody like me who blesses you and say
that's a good value proposition no
there's only one way get an order that's
it so you keep trying to get orders
around this value that you're going to
provide and you modify it as you go
along because you're learning fast and
each time you get turned down that's an
opportunity to improve not an
opportunity to get depressed okay and
now you go back and refine it with real
customer data how am i doing on time
five whoops okay all right so this is
about the value of outsiders but
customer's verifying here's I want to
talk about the graphical approach to
value propositions so this is the first
version of this was a data warehouse
application that an early-stage company
we put together
for sales and marketing executives of
large companies and before our solution
rolled in analysts who are I hired to
recommend action to management we're
spending all their time running around
to the silos of information right
gathering up the information organizing
it and taking action
this is a generalized chart here could
be selling it could be developing could
be supporting right it could be whatever
it is that this particular entity and
the enterprise has to do the after
picture with our $300,000 solution
gathering and organizing is automatic
enabling the analyst to spend a much
bigger portion of their bandwidth taking
action in a much faster period of time
this difference in time has huge value
for the customer of this system who in
this room doesn't get that picture
nobody's gonna raise their hand I
understand that all right the it because
of its elegant simplicity the first
version of that took us an awful long
time to develop there wasn't even a time
dimension all right let me give you
another example how many of you have at
one point in your life installed
something difficult technical
technically like DSL right or ISDN and
so you go in and you go to the FAQ
database and you ask for answers and you
don't get the answers you said give me
an expert you talk to that person for 30
seconds and say I know more than you do
give me a better expert all right and
hopefully move from wherever that person
is overseas to somebody in the US so
along the way and you escalate you
escalate now before solution in this
case most of the answers are provided
down here these answers are much more
expensive than these answers right and
customer satisfaction isn't very good we
provide this collaborative solution
where customers of a customer can
provide support and now the answers are
provided in this profile and customer
satisfaction is much better clear easy
to get you see the elegance of a very
simple graphical approach to describing
what you're doing for your customer now
this is the value proposition for that
scenario right we reduce the cost of
we improve customer response kind of
things and that's the level of
simplicity I'm suggesting that you want
to try to achieve one page of PowerPoint
large font not many bullets it's hard to
do very hard to do but very very
powerful right for your entry into the
market okay
the next thing you want to do is
understand what different title types
care about all right as derived so you
know the CEO is about the stock price
and the chief sales officer is about
revenue and the finance officer is about
asset protection and cash flow all right
so you need to craft messages that
appeal to the title type that you're
going after and sometimes you have to
start at a lower level sponsor and maybe
the messages have to change as you move
from one level to the next this is that
value pain matrix I told you about all
right where what we have to do with that
here is the problems we solve forget the
details and up at the top of the titles
and then we test for the attributes I
described on that previous chart and we
sell a given problem to a given
executive that has all of the attributes
that we're looking for we don't try and
sell everything to everybody we're very
selective about the problem we solve and
what we sell and we also can help
ourselves prioritize the problems we
solve so we maybe spend our engineering
resources on the ones that are most
important to the target market that
we're going after okay so this is a
value messaging architecture I suggest
moving from the top down and what you
want to do is understand some problems
you could solve in different markets
that leads you to some value premises
and we iterate that we test right and we
iterate until we find some good ones so
the initial set might look like this
where we have a whole bunch of problems
we could solve usually this list when I
initially talk to a company is a beats
at least 10 to 15 long and we need to
sort it down to two or three and several
candidate markets leading to several
value premises and what you want to do
is test and select
and minimize the set again for clarity
and simplicity in what you're doing and
going to market this is the model of
integrated sales management process I've
talked about we probably aren't going to
have time to get through all of this but
this is a sales cycle model alright and
the important thing here when you're
developing a sales process model is what
are we asking the customer to do measure
where deals are the success of your
sales efforts according to customer
commitment
not according to salesperson assumption
about where the deal is and this is what
a real one looks like and where you have
explicit exit criteria if one stage to
the next according to customer
commitment and and if you needed to talk
to me offline we could talk more about
that the other thing that's really
important is to recognize that no sales
process is serial there are a variety of
paths and the most important item on
this chart of this complex sales process
is when to stop you should have rules
about when to not continue selling for a
given opportunity and you develop those
over time we tend to focus on the order
activity and sales people hope a deal is
going to close and so we have long cell
cycles and what you need to do as you
develop sales teams is to develop rule
sets to prevent your sales teams from
doing that because it results in very
high selling costs ok the other thing is
that you need to look at funnel dynamics
this is a pipeline requirements model
that says if we want this much revenue
how many touches do we need to make how
many suspects do we need to touch right
and the answer is it's 2 orders of
magnitude larger than you think it is so
you know early on you've got some
investors and advisors and they give you
four broker contacts and then you're in
your mind that equals three orders
doesn't happen that way ok you asked
about the rules and I got some notes in
there that you can read through on how
you approach your first customer the
ingredients of the deal and closing the
deal operating as equals is really
really important do not assume you are
an inferior organization or entity when
you're dealing with these large
corporations ok the only reason they
will deal with you is they think
that you're the right resource for
solving their problem and closing the
sale becomes easier when you've done all
the preparatory stuff okay the next most
important thing is get them
referenceable modify your value
propositions and publish your references
on your website in documents all right
yeah I have a client who has great
reference ability and his customers will
not let him publish the references and
he is having trouble expanding in his
market channel issues I'm not going to
spend any time covering that there's
some stuff in here about positioning and
you can read all that there is a
template for developing a positioning
statement I suggest you do that and
that's a summary page there so I think
I'll end and ask are there any further
questions yes you mean that I'm going to
sell it to somebody else
well because your your interest is
served by me developing a solution that
serves the broad market your interest is
not served by my company becoming your
custom engineering department because
you'll end up with a one-off that isn't
baked in the in in the world doesn't
have the input of all the resources or
of everyone and the other answer is I
don't I'm not in the business of
becoming your customer design department
so no thank you
down the street somebody who doesn't
have that concern okay